hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is my job to
interview and deconstruct world-class
performers from all different fields
my guest today super exciting long time
in the making
dr mark plotkin you can find him on
twitter at doc
mark plotkin p-l-o-t-k-i-n is an
ethno-botanist who serves as president
of the amazon conservation team you can
find that at amazonteam.org
which is partnered with 55 tribes to map
and improve management
and protection of 80 million acres of
ancestral rainforests
educated at harvard yale and tufts
platican has spent much of the past four
decades studying the shamans and healing
plants of tropical america from mexico
to argentina
although much of his work focuses on the
rainforests of the northeast
amazon he is best known to the general
public as the author of the book
tales of a shaman's apprentice one of
the most popular books about the
rainforest ever published
his new book published by oxford press
is the amazon
subtitle what everyone needs to know
this episode is brought to you by
pornhub just kidding
this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic which
is part of my morning routine also part
of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are a
number of ways that i use
for sigmatic in the mornings i regularly
start
with their mushroom coffee instead of
regular coffee and it doesn't taste
like mushroom let me explain this first
of all zero sugar
zero calories half the caffeine of
regular coffee it's easy on my stomach
tastes amazing and all you have to do is
add
hot water i use travel packets i've been
to
probably a dozen countries with various
products from four sigmatic and their
mushroom coffee
is top of the list that's number one
i travel with it i recommend it i give
it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60 percent
of americans or more who drink coffee
daily consider switching it up
this stuff is amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive
enhancement side easy on the system side
energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize chaga it is nicknamed the king
of the mushrooms it is excellent for
immune system support so needless to say
i am focused on that right now myself
and so i will often have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself
sane cordyceps excellent for endurance
they have a whole slew of
options that you can check out every
single batch is third party lab tested
for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff to make sure
that what gets into your hands
is what you want to put in your mouth
and they always offer
a 100 percent money back guarantee so
you can try it risk-free
why not i've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling lions mane coffee i
literally have a mug
full of it in front of me right now and
this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39
off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39
off it's a lot they're best selling
lions main coffee bundles
to claim this deal you must go to
4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on
their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's
f o u r s i g m a t i c
dot com tim to get yourself some awesome
and delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they're worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom
of my feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it
in fact as massage reinvented on some
level helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n try theragon risk-free
for
30 days there's no substitute for the
gen 4 theragon with an oled screen
that's oled for those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app
an incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragun.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine
use them on their it bands after long
runs there are a million ways to use it
and the gen fourth era guns
start at just 199 i said i have two
i have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves these soft
attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
mark welcome to the show tim good to be
here and
we were chatting before we hit record i
said my audience likes
stories and specifics and you said i
might have a few of those and certainly
based on what i know of you based on our
conversations
based on suggestions from friends who
know you
i think we will have no shortage of
ground to cover
and i thought we could start with a name
and a person who fascinates me endlessly
and that is richard evan schulte's and
i would love if you could explain who
this is
and how you crossed paths with this
person well schulte's is often
called the father of ethnobotany and
schulte's
who passed away about 20 years ago when
when he was told this would often say
well you know ethnobotany started with
the pharaohs and i'm not quite that old
so he had a marvelous sense of humor and
seeing him in the field i think this is
really one of the ways
he won his indigenous colleagues over he
might have been a world famous
harvard professor but ultimately a very
down to earth very early
wonderful smart kind conscientious
fellow
schulte's taught for many years at the
harvard botanical museum
and he influenced people uh far and wide
not just his students
like me or tim plowman or way davis but
people
even that knew of his work and and
didn't take his course people like allen
ginsberg
great schulte's fans people like the
great biologist
eo wilson were schulte's fans so his
effect on popular culture and on science
were as i said far and wide
and this great new institute tim that
you helped start at the johns hopkins
university bringing some of these
entheogens some of these hallucinogenic
principles to bear on so-called
uncurable incurable diseases like ptsd
or schizophrenia
in a sense traces back to a lot of
schulte's work because schulte is the
one
who went into the sub-tropical forests
of southern mexico and oaxaca in the 30s
and came up with the magic mushrooms and
schulte is the one who went
into the rain forest the northwest
amazon in the 40s and came out with
ayahuasca so his impact positive impact
on the world
is still being felt and i want a second
what you just said
in the sense that much of my
fascination and thinking on
ethnobotany which i want you to define
for us in a moment
comes from reading the work of schulte's
and i have one book for example that
i've traveled with for many many many
years
which is plants of the gods which i'm
sure you've seen which
in which was not only uh co-authored by
richard evan schulte's but also
albert hoffman the first person to
synthesize lsd 25 and then
christian reich although i'm not sure if
that's how he pronounces his name in
german that is how it is spelled
and what is ethnobotany since we'll be
we'll be digging under the hood
with this quite a bit you know in the
broad sense ethnobotany is simply
the relationship between plants and
peoples but
in popular culture ethnobotany is the
search for medicinal plants
in the rain forest from tribal shamans
so you can go broad
or you can go narrow but it has to do
with plants and peoples
the bottom line is that schulte is
taught and schulte's believed
and taught the rest of us to believe
that much of human culture
is based on our relationship with plants
there's evidence to indicate that many
of the world's religions had their
beginning in the effect of these magical
plants
on the minds of our ancestors and as we
know the effect of these plants and
these fungi and these frogs we now know
on our minds is having a very positive
effect
when used correctly either in
traditional settings
under the care of traditional healers
who really know their stuff
or in the hands of western physicians
who are beginning to discover
the incredible power and potential of
these compounds
the bottom line is that these
entheogenic hallucinogenic compounds in
the hands of shamans
who i work with are as essentially
vegetal scalpels
that allow these men and in some cases
these women
to understand analyze treat
and sometimes cure emotional ailments
uh brain ailments that our own
physicians
yet cannot one of the things that
impresses me most about you
and schulte's by extension but that
impresses me about you
is your field work you have traveled
extensively in the field
and have interacted with so many
different
tribes so many different nations of
people and i'm curious to know
when you were bitten by the bug so to
speak when did this
journey start for you oh it started on a
cool september night
in 1974 i had dropped out of college
and was working at harvard and a
colleague of mine says you know harvard
has a night school
and there's this extraordinary harvard
professor
who went down to the amazon in 1941
and essentially disappeared essentially
went native for about 14 years
i just want to pause to say for people
14 years just let that
sink into your mind for a second and
this was just a place of time this is in
the
what the 30s 41 to 194.
okay please continue sorry to interrupt
and so schulte used to
entice the students gave a version of
his very famous lecture on the
plant hallucinogens of the northwest
amazon
and there was this one slide this one
image that changed my life forever
and it was a picture of black and white
picture that had
three indigenous peoples in
uh barcloff mass and grass skirts
schulte said here you see three yokuna
indians doing the kayari
dance to keep away the forces of
darkness the one on the left has a
harvard degree
next slide please
that image got me hooked got me hooked
on plants
got me hooked on indigenous peoples got
me hooked on the amazon
what was your next step or the step that
led it to becoming a career for you
how did you take that interest and
translate it into a trajectory
well you know that famous saying of
pasture which is that chance favors the
prepared mind so it wasn't dumb luck
but there were certainly a lot of luck
involved i had dropped out of college
and i was working at a museum and was
you know looking for adventures they say
and there was this one
incredible graduate student who himself
was sort of legendary
and he said there are rumors of an
endangered
man-eating crocodilian called the black
caiman
in the northeast amazon in a country
called french guiana this forgotten
little
ex-colony in the northeast shoulder of
south america
you want to go
and i signed up then and there so what
was it
just to backtrack for a second about and
i'm not going to spend too much time on
schulte's but i think the parallels are
interesting
what was it that caught the interest
and peaked the curiosity of say a
ginsburg or an e.o wilson what was it
about him how was he portrayed
well schulte's was essentially a
trickster and i mean that in the very
positive shamanic sense of the word you
see this man this this elderly man in a
white lab coat with a crew cut and a
harvard tie
he looked like the straightest lace
fellow in harvard square and this is
culturally the end of the 60s beginning
of the 70s
yet when he talked and told his stories
and showed his pictures
he was this wild man who went down to
the jungle and did all these tribal
dances and did all of these tribal
drugs and i thought wow you know that
great quote of walt whitman's that
everybody cites about i hold multitudes
well there were schulte's multitudes the
ultimate pillar of the establishment
and the ultimate swashbuckling explorer
all in the same person i i have no idea
if
if there is any connection here but when
i first discovered schulte's
it made me think there had to be some
type of historical
basis for indiana jones minus the
theft of of artifacts
but the the similarities are pretty
striking so aside from the
physical appearance i suppose well this
is always a big debate in the academic
community where people say you're
indiana jones nor you're not no i'm not
indiana jones back and forth who is with
indiana jones is a fictional character
indiana jones was a tomb robber
but indiana jones fired the imagination
of many of us who made a living out of
tropical research
so the net effect was tremendously
positive
but remember that that elements of
shields which are correct were
baked into the indiana jones archetype
elements of schulte's were also baked
into
sean connery in the movie medicine man
so he wasn't just portrayed by harrison
ford he was also portrayed by sean
connery
pretty amazing for a straight-laced
harvard professor
so lest people think that shaman
shaman whatever we want to use as a term
i suppose kudander in this case if we're
talking about spanish would be limited
to hallucinogens could you speak
to this is a story i've heard you tell
but your foot injury and
as as a way to just provide a little
more surrounding context for the
conversation we're going to have
well people need to understand that the
amazon
is full of different cultures uh when
you're looking at indigenous cultures is
between three and four hundred
a minority of those are ayahuasca
drinkers
okay a minority of those are
coca-chewers so when people say to me
what do indians in the amazon want or
what are shamans like you're dealing
with a lot of diversity here
and that's something that the general
public doesn't really seem to get
now i've done a lot of my work in the
northeast amazon
on the surinam brazil border and there
is no ayahuasca there
there are no hallucinogenic fungi there
or if there is they don't take them
and these people are still masters of
the rain forest
these people still are master
diagnosticians
and healers no shaman just like no
physician can cure everything
and there are different forms of
expertise and different forms of healing
even within amazonian cultures and
here's an example
i was in the northeast amazon where i've
worked for decades
and i came into the village and the
shame and it was an old friend of mine
said
uh you're limping and i said yeah you
know i hurt my foot
and uh it doesn't seem to be healing
very well and he says
and i'll never forget this he says take
off your shoe
and give me a machete
[Laughter]
and it did as i was told he walked over
to a palm tree which was about three
meters away
scraped off a fern growing on the palm
tree
threw it in the fire applied it to my
foot burned the hell out of me
threw it in a pot and had me drink it
now
the pain stopped almost instantaneously
now understand
that when i injured my foot i put on
heat i put on cold i took aspirin didn't
work i went to the doctor
she gave me a cortisone shot didn't
really work
i went to a masseuse went to an
entrepreneur didn't work
and this guy cured me on the spot so
i don't understand how it worked
chemically or spiritually or
shamanically but my foot got better
now seven months later it came back and
i was back in the rain forest and he
fixed it now that's ten years ago
and it doesn't hurt so who would you
rather be treated by
again the point being that these guys
can't cure everything
but sometimes sometimes they can cure
things that our own physicians our own
masseuses our own ayurvedic physicians
cannot
and that's why i am so anxious to make
sure
that these healing traditions are
preserved these healing plants and fungi
are preserved
and that these cultures have room
and breathing room to exist in a world
which is pressing in on all
sides and as we know from the headlines
uh covet 19 is pressing in particularly
heavily
one of my favorite quotes of yours that
i've found is and please correct me if
i'm getting this
wrong it might be a paraphrase but
western medicine is the most successful
system of healing ever devised
but it has holes right and then i think
they put some ellipses in there so i
probably omitted a bunch
in the middle but what types of first
you can correct that and then could you
elaborate on what you see as holes well
i think it's quite clear to all of us
that that western medicine can't cure
everything anybody who's lost a relative
to cancer
anybody who has lost a relative to a
suicide anybody who
has trouble sleeping anybody who's
stressed out
western medicine doesn't seem to be able
to cure many cases
of these ailments and again no
shamanic system chinese medicine doesn't
have all the answers all of these
systems do something well
and all of these systems need to be
protect for their own sake
and for the betterment of of all of us
the medical office of the future if we
get it right i believe
is going to have a physician is going to
have a shame and is going to have a
masseuse therapist
is going to have a nutritionist all of
these things that
that should be working together so it
shouldn't be
you know the the physician versus the
medicine man or woman
it should be ways of combining that now
i don't think that we're ever going to
see
a healer where it's going to be a woman
uh using ayahuasca
and antibiotics and ayurvedic therapy
and massage therapy one one person just
can't contain all that stuff
which is why you need different people
uh maintaining and practicing these
different systems
there's such a breadth of subject matter
and unless you want to go an inch deep
and a mile wide
it seems like you really need to
specialize and there are a couple of
notes here i have that i'd love to
explore just to kind of show how
how much territory there is to explore
could you
please speak to electric eels and
dolphins i can't wait to hear this
because i don't i
don't know what comes after the question
but new discoveries in the amazon
regarding electric eels and dolphins
well electric eels are hard to miss
they're eight foot slabs of meat that
send out
jedi-like impulses that paralyze stun
and sometimes kill their prey
so this isn't something that's a recent
discovery electric guilds have been
studied for 250 years
linnaeus himself described the first
electric eel
volta built the first battery inspired
in part by his studies of electric eels
and just last year 2019 we found
two new species of electric heels and
one of them shot out 20 percent
more electricity than electric yields
were known to produce
the point here being if we still don't
know how many species of electric hills
there
are and now we're studying this to find
ways of
building new micro batteries which we
can implant
within the human body to power
electrical devices
think what else is out there that isn't
eight feet long and hard to miss
and so the excitement is to find stuff
like this
the flip side of it is watching it be
destroyed as we all see
last year with the amazon fires the pace
of destruction picking up in brazil
so it's both exciting and disheartening
at the same time
is the dolphin example also one of new
species being discovered
same thing and and again i want to
emphasize that it shouldn't be about
protecting species whether
it's here at home in austin texas or
peru or california or wherever
it shouldn't be about protecting species
because they can cure cancer
or because they can teach us how to make
new batteries i think
species in general and conservation in
general
is an ethical exercise we shouldn't be
destroying species their own stupidity
and our greed
because sometimes sometimes sometimes
these things turn out to be
life-changing
now in terms of the pink dolphin of the
amazon
they just found a new species of a pink
dolphin how do you miss pink dolphins
okay but the uruguayan river dolphin is
a different species
so again we're seeing that big large
conspicuous well-studied
creatures still have secrets that can
share with us
and they might help revolutionize
certain aspects of medicine
like it seems possible with these new
electric eels or it might just be a cool
species
that we can go down there and see and
enjoy because one thing you have to
remember when people talk about well we
can't afford conservation because we
need to develop
the fact is that tourism eco-tourism is
the second biggest
industry in the world and as we
live in an ever urbanizing planet
people have more and more desire and
need to commune with nature
so the value of these wild dolphins and
electric eels and all the other cool
things around the world
only increases if we protect them and
their oceans and coral reefs and
rainforests and deserts
in which they live so let's hop from
some of these what you would think would
be
very conspicuous animals that have been
missed and by mist i suppose we should
say by western
science not necessarily by the people
who live there on the ground
could you explain what yopo is please
yopo is the great undiscovered
hallucinogen of the amazon everybody
focuses on ayahuasca
well all for good reason however there
is
a very powerful lewisengen my personal
favorite
in the north central amazon centered on
the venezuela brazil border
and it's called yopo it's a
hallucinogenic snuff many people saw
this in these famous films by napoleon
chanyan
anthropology 101 and this is
a tree sap or less recognized
a leguminous crushed seed
because these are very different
hallucinogens that the anomaly blow up
their nose for the purpose of divination
and healing and it is quite an
extraordinary experience
because it hurts like hell for a few
minutes and then
it is an extremely visual
spiritual trip that lasts for 20 minutes
and then you feel absolutely wonderful
afterwards
so for all of us who take an lsd and
went through that black period
remember that's why the stones wrote
painted black you feel better afterwards
immediately afterwards which in my
experience is is unique
and it just goes to point that
there are other mind-altering substances
that are still out there it's not just
all about ayahuasca and i'll give you a
concrete example
my late friend lauren mcintyre was lost
on the brazil peru border in 1969
was taken in by a group of uncontacted
peoples called the matzahs who had a
very ferocious
reputation and they were the ones that
introduced him to hallucinogenic frogs
now known as
as kempo quite widely i learned about
this from
mcintyre i put this in a ted talk i gave
a few years ago
and when i went to one of the villages
in which i work in south surinam
i gave my ted talk in the tribal
language
and when i showed the magic frog from
peru one of the shamans stopped me and
said oh we have that frog here and i
said
no you don't that's from peru and he
goes no no we have it here and i said no
no it's
it's from pru it's like you never heard
of this place it's thousands of miles
away
that frog does not occur here and i said
no way and he says yeah it's here but
it's in the canopy
and i said what do you use it for and he
said so we use it for hunting magic just
like those indians you're talking about
and i said i've been working here over
30 years and you never told me this
and he said well you've been working
here over 30 years and you never asked
me
and by the way there's another frog that
we use for the same purpose
so i was able to collect and identify
this frog
completely different family it's not
like sometimes you know the next species
over will have the same compounds in it
completely different family and actually
some analysis had been done with this
and it contains bufotenan which is a
hallucinogenic principle
so once again the indians right in the
western scientist was wrong
and by hunting magic that means they
consume this to
divine beforehand or they use it for the
hunt itself
they use it the night before the hunt to
see
where the animals will be and as a
western scientist
this makes no sense to me but as an
ethnobotanist when people tell me stuff
indigenous people tell me stuff that i
found hard to believe it's important to
put aside my disbelief
and be willing to listen and learn and
the classic account of this was
published by my buddy peter gorman
who heard about lauren mcintyre's first
encounter with this drug
and went down to the northwest amazon
where he had a fair amount of experience
and he tried it and he said i took the
stuff in my mind i saw this taper
crossing the river at a place i knew
the next day we went hunting we got to
that crossing and there was the taper
raises a lot of questions doesn't it it
raises many questions more questions
than answers but that's what makes this
field of study endlessly fascinating
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
people always ask me what podcasts i
listen to and the truth is
i don't actually listen to that many
given all the projects that i'm working
on
given producing this podcast one
exception is
business wars from the podcast network
wondering you know a lot of their shows
already
as at least 20 of onedri's shows have
reached number one on apple podcasts
now business wars is a great show that
profiles
epic stories of competition so you might
have say wwe
versus wcw which is a great one you've
got
netflix versus blockbuster and that
entire story
one great way to listen to business wars
is with a wondry plus
membership which allows you to enjoy
business wars one week before the
episodes are available anywhere else
and ad free so you can listen to the
remarkable stories of groundbreaking
rivalries like amazon versus walmart
ebay versus paypal and coke versus pepsi
uninterrupted
you might also enjoy pizza wars domino's
versus pizza hut which explores the
rivalry and special sauce that makes
these brands so successful
and the wonder plus membership also
gives you access to the exclusive
business wars season
playboy versus penthouse this is a
really really fun season
they're very short very dramatic easy to
listen to
i enjoy them a lot so check out wonder
plus today with this exclusive offer for
listeners of this podcast
you can get 25 off a one-year membership
at wonderi
that's w-o-n-d-e-r-y-wundryplus.com
tim to start enjoying business wars and
much more that's
wonder plus w-o-n-d-e-r-y-p-l-u-s
wanderyplus.com tim to enjoy
and join laundry plus
let me ask you another question related
to yopo so you said your personal
favorite for someone who does not have
any personal experience how would you
describe the differences between
yopo and say ayahuasca aside from the
duration of the experience
you know somebody asked me recently tim
about ayahuasca if i'd taken it and i
said well you know i mean that's
nobotness it's my job
and they said well how many times have
you taken it and i said
87 i think and
as you know uh these experiences are
often very different it depends on where
you are in life it depends what's on
your mind depends on the shame and
depends on the mix because
most ayahuasca mixes are comprised of
different ad mixes by the real masters
and it depends the shame and say it
depends on what you need
sometimes you're going to the ninth
dimension and making love to the goddess
the river
under the water and sometimes you don't
see anything and sleep deeply and when
you ask the shaman about it
he or she will say well you got what you
needed so it's very difficult to say oh
ayahuasca is this and yopa was that and
the magic mushrooms are that
but i will say this the yanamami with
whom i had the great pleasure to live
and study this stuff make two kinds of
yopo
okay one is made from the sap of a
varola tree
which is essentially an amazonian nutmeg
remember nutmeg is a tree from the
southeast asian tropics and if you read
the autobiography of malcolm x he talks
about sneaking into the prison
commissary at night
and stealing nutmeg so they could get a
buzz catch a buzz out of it
now i find the uh yopo from the varola
snuff to be very very very visual it
takes you a different place
divisions are extraordinary much like
i've seen in some ayahuasca experiences
and then with the other yopo which is
made from the crushed seeds
of a savannah tree is primarily auditory
you're hearing extraordinary things you
can hear everything in the jungle
it is unlike any other antigenic
substance which i have taken
and that to me are very striking
differences but again the details
are in primarily who's the shaman
what is he or she treating you for what
is the dosage
so i really can't be more specific than
that well thank you for making the
attempt nonetheless
let's talk about this word shaman shaman
it gets used a lot it seems like
everyone on facebook who plays the
didgeridoo does
yoga or has been to burning man is now
shaman these days
for you what does that designation
connotate and understanding that that
that is not the word
that these people would use to describe
themselves necessarily in these
indigenous
communities but what does that signify
to you what are the prerequisite
skills or experiences that would lead
someone in your mind to qualify for that
you know the etymology of the word when
i looked it up was he who knows
and i think you know there are many
terms for you and i would think of as a
shaman
it is somebody who is an expert healer
somebody who is a keeper of the
traditions a keeper of the laws
a cycle pump the person who conveys
souls to the underworld
and one way to contrast it with our own
healers and why i think
some of these shamans are so effective
is in our system if you're sick you go
to the general practitioner and if that
doesn't work she sends you to
a specialist and if that doesn't work he
sends you to a psychiatrist
whereas the shame in incense it's kind
of one-stop shopping
and there's two things that stick in my
mind is how you know you're dealing with
the real thing
one is in the northwest amazon if you
ask somebody if they're a shaman
they will never say yes they will say
well some say that i am
or who knows and then anybody who pounds
their chest like some sort of tribal
tarzan and says yes i'm a shaman or i'm
the great shaman or whatever
isn't a shaman secondly i gave
the commencement address at tulane
medical school a couple years ago in my
hometown of new orleans
and the night before i had a few drinks
with the dean and i said
i got to ask you something i said why
did you ask an ethnobotanist to
give the graduation speech in a medical
school and this after a lot of wine he
said
well we wanted jimmy carter but we
couldn't afford him
but the reason i bring up that example
to answer your question
is one of the great shamans the
northwest amazon a real ayahuasca
master uh don loreano he's long gone now
of the ingano peoples i once asked him
how long does it take you to become a
shaman
a taita that's what in their language
that's what they call a shame how long
did it take you to become a taita and he
says
you know my son he says in your system
you have to go to school for three years
to become a doctor
he says in your years he says
i'm over 90. he says
i'm still learning i thought
that is a true shaman let me sub in for
quite a few listeners out there to
follow up on your mention of 87 or so
times at the cup with ayahuasca
the question that one might ask is why
so many times
right why keep doing it is this not
supposed to be the
wham bam thank you van damme one-stop
shopping where you come in and you have
this transformative experience
why keep going back to the well how
would you respond to that
it's an excellent question and like i
said i'm an ethnobotanist it's my job
seven of the tried to work with are the
original ayahuasca tribes these are the
same tribes that taught it to schulte's
so when you want to work with an
ayahuasca and he says well we have to do
this in ceremony
we do okay very very very few occasions
tim have i gone down there and said
i'm having a problem i have an issue i
can't deal with i really want to have a
ceremony
in almost every single case it was part
of
bonding with these people it was part of
communicating with these people
it was never like hey i hear he's a
great champion let me give this a whirl
i i don't work that way i mean you know
as an ethnobotanist you don't want to be
a shame and snob like oh well
i know a real shame and you don't sort
of stuff that's nonsense however
it does give you access to this shamanic
world
and you're dealing with the real deal
and i want to bring up our mutual friend
michael pollan
you know i hope everybody's read michael
michael's great book on hallucinogenic
plants and practice
and one thing that comes through
repeatedly time and time again
is this is not a toy
people with mental ailments who are
often the ones who go down into the
rainforest in search of these things
often come back worse so that you really
need to be
dealing with the real deal and stuff
that you buy on the internet
or workshops you you hear about on the
internet
um you got to be real careful because
it's not like smoking a joint
you know you can really have a bad trip
it can really do you harm
and so the point here is not to say okay
well i've done it
87 times tim you've only done it 83
times so
you know i'm a bigger stud than you are
that's ridiculous
i mean i remember when i was back in
college and people would like well
the people who smoked the most dope were
supposed to be the wisest
how'd that work out right uh
there are people that go and take
ayahuasca once and they say i got it
i'm done that's i got what i needed i'm
never gonna do it again or the shaman
will tell them
okay you don't need to do this anymore
or you need to take another cup or don't
you dare take another cup
you know this is how it has to be
regarded you need
you wouldn't go to a doctor that you you
heard about on the internet who didn't
have an md
and wasn't certified why would you
undergo
something so profound and frankly so
risky
with just some fly by that operation
yeah i want to mention a few things to
underscore
a few of the points that you made so the
first michael pollan for those
interested
in his book how to change your mind is
exceptional i also have two interviews
with him on this podcast
great 30 000 foot view as well as
experiential account
of someone who is psychedelically naive
researching not just the history but the
current day
and also having his own first person
experiences
and to the point related to risk just to
give a few
concrete examples so that people
understand what can happen
in some areas of peru and certainly
hallucinogens are not limited
to peru these plants and there are many
different types of plants are not
limited to peru but
that has become one of the top
destinations for those
seeking some type of transcendent
experience or who are desperate to
address a problem they've not been able
to address
and in some areas galba and other parts
of peru
there are a lot of
basically walking dead i'm not going to
say dead but you have these
westerners who have had psychotic breaks
or just wandering around homeless i mean
it's a non-trivial problem
and it's really important to understand
that these
compounds can cause you know what roland
griffiths at hopkins would call
ontological shock where your perception
of reality is so
fundamentally shifted that you cannot
get back
to more your boat you cannot get back to
the dock
and i know someone personally who
actually you know multiple people who
went down he did a
dieta which involved fasting and
consuming a plant
in this case chirixenango which is very
valuable in a number of contexts but
whether it was the administration or his
genetic predisposition or any number of
other factors he was
untethered from reality for a good i
want to say was between one and two
months and his family had to fly down to
south america
and the only way they could get him on a
plane was by convincing him that he
was god and that he would be doing them
a great service
it would be a demonstration of his power
to get on this plane with them to fly
back to the united states i mean this is
not to say a typical experience but it's
not altogether
rare alternatively so i don't have to
take us
too far into the sort of encyclopedic
list of these types of
side effects but you have to treat them
very carefully so if you're
you wouldn't go on craigslist to find a
neurosurgeon and i don't think you
should you know buy
ayahuasca for your slow cooker on the
dark web and
invite your friend who's had one
hallucinogenic experience to
be your shaman for the weekend anyway
i'll get off my soapbox
well yeah i completely agree and in my
new book the amazon what everybody needs
to know i talk about ayahuasca
and i point out this obscure lyanna that
was dug up in a sense by schulte's
in the 40s and 50s is now being taken
from from israel to istanbul
and you take it at your own risk i get a
lot of calls and emails from people
saying where should i go to take it it's
like
i'm a conservationist i'm an
ethnobotanist i'm not
running an eco-tourism operation for
psychonauts so
don't even ask me but understand that
there's risks
like i said earlier hallucinations are
vegetal scalpels
and scalpels can heal you and scalpels
can hurt you they are the vegetal or
fungal
two-edged swords so this idea and i
and i get this all the time people say
oh well it's a plant so it can't hurt me
really ever hear a straight nine yeah
hemlock yeah belly you know
a lot of i'm all in favor of plant
medicines or fungal medicines but the
idea that they have all the answers and
there's no downside
is as ridiculous as saying if if a
doctor doesn't know it nobody else can
agree and i want to talk about
more things that can hurt or heal let's
start with vampire bats or maybe not
vampire bats specifically but
you were bitten by a vampire bat this is
something i did not
know or is it maybe a story about
someone else okay
please say more uh this is recounted in
my
first book tales for shaman's apprentice
which talks about my 15-year search for
medicinal plants
in the northeast amazon and i was on the
surname brazil border on the surinam
side packing my gear to hike across the
border and into brazil and remember
americans don't typically arrive in
brazil on foot
and i was in the camp and i had my
lantern on and i felt this terrible
pain in my leg and i looked down and
there was a bat attached to my leg
biting me slicing into my leg and i mean
i was bleeding like a stuck pig
i yelled and my indigenous guide came
running in
took a machete and sliced it in half and
i just stood there bleeding all over the
floor
and i said to him oh my god i said
am i going to get rabies and die and he
said
no and then he said what's rabies
[Laughter]
so he was right i didn't get rabies and
die
but the reason that i was bleeding like
a stuck pig is that vampire bats have
anticoagulants in their saliva much as
leeches do if you feed on blood for a
living you don't want it to clot
right that means dinner's over so this
saliva this compound is being looked at
in the lab
and it's got a great trade name draculin
so the important thing here tim is that
are you serious is that what it's called
that's what it's called you can look it
up oh my god
that's incredible uh the important thing
here is you know i started out working
at the world wildlife fund and we were
all about save the elephants and save
the pandas and save the whales
and that's great but there's not much
coming out of elephants pandas and
whales
in the medicinal realm it's often the
creepy crawlies
often the poisonous things like
poisonous snakes which led to
the birth of ace inhibitors of you know
billion dollar drug industry on its own
and so it's sometimes a very good reason
for saying we can't just protect the
cute cuddly
things that are appealing to us
emotionally sometimes it's the nasty
mean hairy aggressive insects
scorpions or other things like that that
might have real potential
yeah if i'm not mistaken i mean if
you've undergone
anesthetic if you trace it back a lot of
the
i want to say some of the early
innovations related to anesthetics were
from curari
and poison darts used in south america
which i would imagine
probably came from frog venom of some
type or toad venom but you could perhaps
speak to that
it's incredible how much knowledge is
possessed
in is is held in the heads of
these let's just call them elder doctors
in the rain forest not by our
credentials but
certainly in their traditions and
i think you've called them one of or the
most endangered species
because in a sense whether it's cute or
cuddly
whether it's a creepy crawly how they
can be used
medicinally or a plant certainly how
they can be used medicinally
has been vetted through trial and error
for
hundreds and thousands of years by some
of these
groups of people and there's a real
question of
how you can preserve that when these
people are being displaced and certainly
the older generations are dying the
younger
folks have perhaps become seduced by
modernity understandably on some levels
and disillusioned with their
traditional medicinal approaches how do
you preserve
and you have done such great work in
this respect but
how do you even hope to try to preserve
that well that was the birth of the
shaman's apprentice program that we run
out of here at the amazon conservation
team
is that i quickly realized decades ago
that i could never collect
all the information schulte could never
collect all the information
and a much better way to preserve it is
within the cultures themselves
and the fact is that no matter how much
hashem and will teach me after decades
and decades and decades of
partnership collaboration friendship
love they're still
teach even more secrets to their kids or
their grandkids
and so the answer we stumbled across me
and my indigenous colleagues was
let's pass it down within the tribe okay
these are
traditional secrets it's not going to be
published it's not going to be marketed
it's up to them
but as long as the young people don't
learn it
we're doomed well through this program
we now have four shamans apprentice
clinics in the northeast amazon
we have one of the first books ever
written by the indians for the indians
in their language
documents all of their medicinal plant
knowledge
we have them running clinics first and
foremost for themselves
and their own culture outsiders are
coming to them for treatments
and it's a living breathing thriving
tradition
where when i went there it was it was
dying out you had all these great
shamans they were like the last of the
mastodons that weren't going to
reproduce
well now they're reproducing and the
point we made the point i made time and
time again was not like
okay you can be a shaman or you can have
an iphone
right you can do both but if we're going
to introduce technology
let's do it in a way which supports the
perpetuation of the culture rather than
replaces it
because when you have the equivalent of
i call it tech bombing where you have
outsiders just come in and give these
guys
all sorts of trinkets you know ipads and
iphones they're very seductive but
let's show them how they can use to
document their traditions to record
grandma and grandpa
not just the medicinal plants the old
songs the legends and things like that
so it's never lost
how do you from a brass text standpoint
tactically on the ground because like
you
i've seen the ipads the big screen tvs
and so on
but used not in a focused way but how
most of the world
and certainly how sometimes i use these
things as a source of entertainment and
distraction
how did you help to
incentivize the participants especially
the younger
generations to help facilitate this
how do you actually yeah what do you do
surprisingly easy
20 years ago the chief of the trio tribe
which is the major tribe in the
northeast amazon who was a friend of
mine at the time still is
said to me we want to get title to our
lands
and we need a map that's what the
government told us
you need a map we didn't know what a map
was they showed us so
we want the help of the amazon
conservation team and i said you got it
and he said so you'll make us a map and
i said no
and he said but you said you're going to
help us and i said we will
and he said so you'll make us a map and
i said we won't
he said i'm confused i said we will not
make a map
we will teach you to make your own map
and we will provide the training and the
technology
to do so which we did so
technology came in specifically to help
them protect
their land to lay their claim to the
traditional territory
and while you're at it why don't you
talk to grandpa and find out all the
names of the rivers
and ask him why those rivers have those
names was it a great battle was it the
home of a sacred spirit
stuff like that so it was introduced
specifically
to protect land and culture now yeah i
mean do they play
games and stuff like that they do but it
was introduced in a serious and
purposeful way
and they have taken it onto themselves
to find new ways to use it i'll give you
an example
if you're a botanist you know that
brazil nuts only live in the amazon
basis that's what i was taught as a
student at harvard
but the trios in mapping their lands
which
crosses the border between brazil and
suriname found 13 stands of brazil nuts
outside the amazon basin because the
guianas are the other side of the
watershed
so they decided to create maps of their
brazil nut trees
because that is a sustainable resource
that was their idea i didn't tell them
to do it
one of the proudest moments in my career
happened this week when i saw a picture
of these same indians in a clinic which
we helped them set up
all of them wearing masks and the
shamans were creating
what they call an immunostimulant
beverage from local plants
and giving it to all the villagers as
part of the ways to keep the
coronavirus at bay so this
shows the perfect marriage of ancient
shamanic wisdom which is the plants
and 21st century knowledge which is the
face masks
okay and the technology has been a very
important part of the
equation so it's not this thing like
let's give them all our technology
because it's cool and we want to show
them that we're cool
nor is it this equally ridiculous idea
of saying oh no they're indians we'll
spoil them if we give them technology
you know they're part of the modern
world and with the exception of the 70
uncontacted tribes in the amazon
everybody has a sense what's going on
how did you or how did they go from
using gps and other tools for mapping
to recording the
and i'm gonna mispronounce this maybe
you can tell me pharmacopia pharmacopeia
both okay great i'll go with both the
the spectrum
of plants and compounds and animals
i suppose that could be used medicinally
as well as
the methods of preparation
and administration how do you make the
jump from
mapping land to that or how is it done
in any instance
because it was a process i went down
there to
collect ethno botanical information
allah's making lists and writing it down
and when they said why do you want to do
this i said
well you know that bible you read in
church i'm not a christian i'm a jew
and if my ancestors had written down
their information we wouldn't have the
bible to learn from today
so i want to work with your shamans to
write down their knowledge
so 20 years from now 200 years from now
your great great great great great great
grandchildren will have your original
wisdom
to learn from well the chief was a
fundamentalist pigeon this was perfect
and we did so so we started writing down
lists of plants and what they're used
for and then
the shamans would prepare for me so i
realized okay well you're actually you
need
you know the dosage you need the
preparation it's not just a they use
species a for headaches that doesn't
really tell you much
and then i i did this all with with
guides my age i started this when i was
27
and after eight years i very proudly
handed the chief a book of his
ethnobotanical wisdom
in his language he had two books in his
language at that point the bible
presented by the missionaries
and the torino epipen pierre the trio
plant medicine handbook
done by me in collaboration with these
shamans it's the power of the written
word
i mean you've written enough books tim
it's the power of the written word that
when you put it in front of somebody
it's written down it carries
much more weight than just you know a
conversation or an interview or anything
like that
that really revolutionized their
thinking of the value of this stuff
so i said look i got you guys started
but ultimately it's not all about me my
first book tales of a shaman's
apprentice
it's kind of a trick title because i'm
not the apprentice
they are but in following me and
and me helping them kids start this
interest in their own traditions
they took it over which is the way it
should be was the book in their native
language to prevent
biopiracy yes it was
yes please continue no i mean i've been
criticized for not publishing this
information in in the technical
literature but
i have no interest in it it's their
secret i'm not gonna reveal a secret
that sold me in confidence so i get
tenure
you know i run a not-for-profit i don't
face that challenge but i wouldn't do it
anyhow
and so the knowledge is first and
foremost for them
and if they want to commercialize it or
sell it somehow good for them
i mean i'll give them advice but i'm not
going to do it i'm not going to do it
for them i'm not going to take what i
know
and i know a lot and make money
commercially i run a not-for-profit
profit is not my my prime motivating
factor in life
so let's take an example just to explore
this a little bit further
male aphrodisiacs so
i was going to say what has your
experience been with them but what i
mean by that
is in in your field studies
i mean we can we can go any direction
you want but in your field experiences
whether it's with the trios in the
northeast amazon or or
elsewhere maybe you could just walk us
through your sort of exposure to this
and the reception from your
western friends and colleagues yeah i
was working with the trio's first trip
i think was 1982 and they kept showing
me this one plant and they say that's a
male aphrodisiac that's a melaphrodisiac
that's male producia
now you have to understand that shaman's
knowledge is individualistic
in that even within the same tribe even
within the same village
very seldom do you have a shaman who
will say i use this plant
for this and i i use this dosage and i
prepare it this way
and so on and so forth it's not a
perfect match okay
it's like our own medicine it's art and
science if you go to three doctors with
one ailment
very seldom do you get the exact same
recommendation in my experience
so i i came back and it but they kept
saying this might mail everybody's
mail so i got back to my office at
harvard i was working in the museum
uh foreign was schulte's at the time and
he said we'll call the medical school
see what they say so i got this guy
on the phone at the medical school
calling here from the harvard botanical
museum
and i said look i found this thing and
they say it's a it's a male aphrodisiac
and he said did you try it i said look
i'm 27.
i wouldn't be able to tell if it worked
or not
so he said well understand there's no
such thing as a male aphrodisiac
and i said what do you mean he says it
was physiologically impossible
and i said well i mean what about
spanish fly he said it's an urban legend
it doesn't work
there is no such thing as a male
aphrodisiac okay fine
a year later i was working with the
wyanna people uh to the east
on the surname french guiana border and
they showed me this other plan they said
it's a male aphrodisiac and three
shamans that have some aphrodisiacs
wasn't even the same family okay once
again you know if something's just one
species over in the same genus
and probably the same compounds
completely different plant completely
different family
and so i i got back to harvard and i
called the medical school and the guy
says oh you're the guy who called last
year i told you there's no such thing no
such thing no such thing
a year later i was working with the
maroons the maroons are afro
amazonians they are the descendants of
escaped slaves they were brought to the
northeast amazon
in the 1700s they got off the slave
ships looked around and said this is
equatorial rainforest
i'll see you white boys later and took
off for the interior
okay and you go in their villages and it
looks like the set of roots it looks
like
you know 17th century west africa and
they showed me a plan
that they said was a male aphrodisiac
different species different genus
different family except these guys
were selling it in town so
i didn't even call the medical school
because i didn't have the same
conversation
a few years later some physicians got i
think it was the dosage wrong on a blood
pressure medicine
and all of a sudden all these guys in
the old folks home are popping woodies
right eureka it's a male aphrodisiac
okay yeah so if a shaman in a red bridge
claw says it's a male aphrodisiac the
guy in
in the white coat says it's impossible a
guy in a white coat stumbles across it
you know it's billions of dollars and
maybe a nobel prize
is there you know this is a side note
this could be a total urban legend i
heard
that the way this could be total fancy
but that the way that viagra
was identified for male enhancement
erectile dysfunction
whatever you want to call it was that
they had called it a fail
for blood pressure or whatever the
primary outcome measure was for the
study
and they asked the subjects these
elderly folks to
return their supplies and
and uh the the men all refused and they
were like
what what the hell is going on here what
is going on here this is very very odd
so in your experience have you seen
any tribes who have
been able to without sort of destroying
setting fire to their own homes
metaphorically speaking
take some of this knowledge and monetize
it
for their benefit have you seen any
success
stories and the reason i ask is one of
the compelling
reasons to say preserve
rainforest and all sorts of different
ecosystems is for
the the medicinal value that might be
contained so i'm wondering if there are
any
success stories it's really a good
question from my colleague
paul cox who's a fellow ethnobotanist
trained at harvard around the same time
i was
and he was making great progress with
some compounds from
american samoa antivirals where the deal
he cut which is the way it should be
done where they would make a keystone
payment in other words
uh let me take this plant and if it
cures aids i'll be back in 17 years with
a billion dollars
you know it's a crapshoot it's a long
shot for any
plant or animal product or fungal
product to make it to the market for a
variety of reasons
but he said okay if you want to study
this in the lab you have to pay these
people
x and then if it passes phase one what
you did then you have to pay them y
and then if it passes phase two you have
to pay them a z
and then if it gets to market they get a
piece of the action
another colleague of mine stephen king
at jaguar health has been developing a
new anti-diarrheal
from tree sap in peru
and has made a lot of progress in
putting money back into these
communities
so i wish i had a great success story to
tell you
about some tribe that made a billion
dollars and save the rainforest and live
happily ever after
the answers aren't completely in but
these were two successful examples that
really
they're looking into further thank you
no that's very
encouraging i really just don't know if
there are any precedents
or sort of deal structures
that have made sense long term and it
sounds like there are some
some case studies that people can you
know tim i think that would what people
fail
there's two failures in this idea of
sustainable development
one is that we have to find x whether
it's the cure for cancer
or an eco-tourism lodge or non-timber
forest products
and they can live happily ever after and
anybody who has a pension or has
stocks knows that you don't put all your
money on one horse even at the racetrack
right
so what we need is a diverse portfolio
as we would call it
where they're making some money from
ecotourism and they're making some money
from handicrafts and they're making some
money from running a shamanic clinic
and and so on and so forth that's the
way to really help these people
the other fallacy is that we just got to
get them a lot of money as much as
possible as soon as possible they'll be
better off
i've seen this time and time again where
these guys make enough money to move to
the city
and actually they don't live in the nice
part of the city they live in the slums
the body of the favela and they're much
worse off
so a little money on a very steady basis
based on non-destructive aspects
of the ecosystem to me is the way to go
and i'll give you an example of that
there's a tribe of hunter-gatherers
called the aquarios they were
essentially dragged out of the forest
right before i started my work in the
70s and 80s in in the northeast amazon
but the other indians regard them as
almost legendary in terms of their
ability to hunt in terms of their
knowledge of the forest
and i was told they had 35 words for
honey
and well i have to report that was an
exaggeration
there's only 34.
i wrote them all down i got together
with my colleagues and said let's create
a project
on sustainable development of honey
we'll show you guys how to build hives
we'll have the aquarios as our
our our technical experts to talk about
what produces the best honey
what's the stainless bees we should be
working with and we're now producing
honey
not a single tree's cut down okay
and they're making money and they have
more honey than ever and it's it's one
of those win-win situations they're
never going to get rich from this
but when they go to town they've got
honey in their pocket which essentially
means money in their pocket is something
they can sell
without having to you know cut down a
mahogany tree
or sell off the lands to gold miners or
anything like that
well that's that that sounds certainly
like tremendous
progress or at least providing a very
viable alternative
to cutting down the mahogany and so on
i would love to explore perhaps the
other side of the coin and what i mean
by that is
i mentioned just a few minutes ago say
finding the or you did also the cure for
cancer the cure for
aids or the cure for fill in the blank
but it strikes me that there's
also and it's certainly this is not my
original thought there is
the avoidance of the next
aids or the next fill in the blank
pandemic could you speak to
your thoughts on preventing pandemics
any policies or lessons that that you
think are
worth underscoring well i did an
editorial recently for the los angeles
review of books it's on my
a personal website markplotkin.com in
which i point out that the pandemic
was caused by abuse of nature
and by that the concrete example of that
is it came
out of a bat that was crammed together
in some fetid cage
in wuhan china and we don't know exactly
how it jumped to the human species
whether it went to a pangolin and then
to a human that part's a little unclear
but it's clear that
this terrible virus originated in the
bat
and our attitude towards abusing these
animals cruelty to animals
is causing real harm i mean hundreds of
thousands if not millions of deaths
trillions of dollars already
and no end in sight so when
indigenous peoples whether they're
pygmies in west africa
or or indigenous peoples in the amazon
tell us we're going to pay a price for
abusing nature
we're paying that price some of the most
extraordinary people i've ever met are
the kogis the kogis
live in northern colombia in the sierra
nevada it's not in the amazon
but they've been called the dalai lamas
of south america they're the most
traditional people
they don't wear shoes they don't have
wrist watches they don't have cell
phones for the most part
and they have been saying and they told
me this in february tim they told me
this in february and march
if we don't stop abusing nature we're
going to pay a terrible price
well guess what they were right and i'm
sure they take no joy in that
but this whole attitude towards
monetizing
everything towards short-term thinking
is destroying the planet on which we
live
is fouling the nest in which we live
so this attitude oh well foreign aid is
a waste of money
and third world people deserve what they
get
uh really how much money have we spent
in the us now on coronavirus
and as i said there's no end in sight so
i really don't like to hear this phrase
what's the silver lining in this
pandemic there's no silver lining
it's terrible but there may be some
lessons learned
and one of those lessons has got to be
abusing wildlife
is a real bad idea bad ethically bad
spiritually but obviously perhaps worst
of all bad
epidemiologically are there any actions
that you would like to see
taken any policies put in place
seems like regulating what markets in
china would be
or is exceptionally challenging but
i haven't been tracking the news or
developments so perhaps steps have been
made
to try to mitigate some risk do you have
any thoughts on on what's
could be done to uh remedy some of these
problems
well as i recall you have extensive
experience in east asian studies and
martial arts and things like that so
maybe you have a better
understanding of the mindset than i do
but
we're all paying a price here the
chinese the americans the canadians the
amazonian indigenous peoples i would
hope
that we as a species can sit down
and say let's have some guidelines here
you know there's a lot of people calling
for an end to the wildlife trade in an
ideal world maybe that would
be possible we don't live in an ideal
world let's control it let's have less
cruelty let's have less
conditions that that lead to diseases
jumping out of these species whether
they're bats or pangolins or armadillos
and i know from
other biologists there as many viruses
in the bats of the amazon
as there are in southeast asia so it's
not just like okay if we shut down the
wet mark at muhan
we're cool okay i'm always
much more in favor of building bridges
and creating alliances
than pointing fingers and saying you
know this person's at fault these the
bad guys i'm the good guy
that seldom works it just goes against
human nature but the same token
the idea that everybody will just get
together and sing kumbaya
is is equally ridiculous the wildlife
trade
is the biggest illegal market
with the sole exception of narcotics
and munitions so we're not talking about
a couple of guys doing bad things on the
side in the back of a market somewhere
in the tropics
we're talking about a lot of power and a
lot of money but if we don't tackle it
the next pandemic is going to be right
behind it this is not a one-off there's
nobody who understands epidemiology
or the wildlife trade thinks okay once
we get past this we're in the clear
nobody and in some respects this was a
real
warning shot i mean it's caused
long-term
economic damage certainly skyrocketing
unemployment
around the world you have many deaths
but it's nowhere near as bad as it could
have been
right this is it's very much a virus
that's kind of designed to trick
smart people in a lot of ways but it's
not nearly
at least as far as we know right now as
lethal as it could have been
right compared to many other viruses
that have
even scarier combinations of are not
the sort of transmissibility and
lethality so
hopefully this will act as a sort of
flare to catch the attention of people
who can
take steps to mitigate some of these
risks well somebody's been working the
amazon for a long time i'm often asked
well
when i look at the amazon rainforest is
the glass half full or half empty
and my response is always the same any
glasses half full is half empty
so as terrible as things are with covert
19
as you said it could be worse i wouldn't
say that's a silver lining
but i would say like you said tim that
it is a wake-up call
and when you look at some of these
terrible hemorrhagic fevers they're even
scarier
but that's not to belittle this virus
which is
killing our species right left and
center so
the focus needs to be on dealing with
this pandemic
but the focus at the same time needs to
be on preventing the next pandemic
when i started working the rainforest in
the 70s many people said to me like well
rainforest who cares about that we have
to worry about zero population growth
now people say to me well the rain
forest who cares about that we need to
worry about climate change
but overpopulation is driving
deforestation of the rain forest
and deforestation of the rain forest
destruction the rain forest is pouring
carbon into the atmosphere and it's the
number two cause
of climate change number two driver of
climate change after fossil fuels
so the idea that oh well let's just
solve
covert 19 and then we can worry about
wildlife and then we can worry about
poverty and then we can worry about
pronounced pandemic no we need to do all
those things now
yeah it's all interrelated and one thing
that
strikes me about your bio and your
stories and looking at your career is
that
much like schulte's you are a boundary
walker right
just like the coyote just like the
trickster
or the raven right i mean you're both
boundary walkers
and we won't go into a whole joseph
campbell
mythological expedition right now but
you're both boundary walkers
and as a boundary walker you've been
very good at
finding common ground common interests
and
building long-term relationships with
people who at face value would seem to
be
very different from yourself and i'd be
interested to hear since i do think that
building bridges is going to be very
important if we want to tackle any of
these issues that we just mentioned
there's going to need to be in the u.s
bipartisan support they're going to need
to be you know as you put at large tents
as we were talking uh before we started
recording could you speak to some of
your
longer-term relationships what they look
like
for instance you mentioned in a note
that you shot me
a shaman that you hadn't seen in 32
years i don't know the story behind that
but could you tell it
i was invited to a conference of
indigenous leaders mostly shamans
i was the only white guy there it took
me
four days to get there that in itself is
a long story which i'll spare you this
time
but when i got there i met an old friend
who was the one who invited me who was a
a tribal leader
and while we're talking his brother
walked up
and he said remember me and i said
yeah he says i haven't seen you
in 32 years you were my father's friend
i walked five days to be here can i give
you a hug
i mean i almost burst into tears
wow i almost burst into tears
i mean how sincere is that but the point
here
is that a long-term relationship allows
you to work with people
whether it's a shaman in the amazon or
whether it's somebody in capitol hill or
somebody
you grew up with based on a level of
trust and friendship and knowledge that
you simply can't do in a hurry
and we're rushing everywhere less so
these days
you just cannot create the connections
to get things done
and if we need system change which the
skull foundation which is one of the
supporters of our work
founded by jeff skull who says we need
system change means that we can't just
tinker around the edges
and what a lot of people don't realize
if you look at the history of
environmentalism particularly in this
country was founded by republicans
the first great environmentalist was
teddy roosevelt and the second greatest
environmentalist in terms of presidents
was richard nixon
also a republican so this whole idea
that
well if you like trees or you like
hunting or you like wildlife you should
be a democrat
or republicans don't believe in this
everybody gets sick everybody wants
clean everybody wants clean water
so this is one thing where there
shouldn't be any political
discord there should be broad agreement
and clearly we need
to work together democrats republicans
independents people elsewhere uh
even in dictatorships you know for the
common good i went to the rio conference
in 92 it was the greatest gathering
of world leaders ever george bush senior
was there fidel castro was there
and this was the probably the greatest
occasion in the history of the world
where everybody put aside their politics
and said we want a better world
not for ourselves so much as for our
kids and our grandkids
that's the attitude we need to have oh
great
i'd like to if you don't mind take a bit
of a left turn we're going to come back
to this but i want to travel back
to the amazon or surrounding areas
for a second because you mentioned the
magic mushrooms
of mexico and
in schulte's and among the
mos detects much of the
fungal medicine work is matriarchal a
lot of women
very female forward that's even an
expression but
it's it tends to be matriarchal and i
i've certainly
seen that there are many you know
ayahuasca among the shipibo people
female have you run into other societies
other tribes other nations
within say south or central america
that have been predominantly matriarchal
when it comes to the
shamanic work or medicine work
interesting question difficult to answer
you hit the two highlights the famous
female shamans of the neotropics
are the masatex in southern mexico and
the shipibo and the amazon
now every tribe that i've worked with
and i work with a number of them
has female healers and sometimes female
shamans they sometimes make that
distinction
they're the ones that tend to focus on
female ailments menstrual problems for
example
childbirth problems or kids things
there are on occasion female shamans
that have met but they're few and far
between i've had many discussions with
shamans around
around the fire at night about why
that's the case and they said
uh women work too hard to have the time
to practice medicine
they do all the work around here right
they they raise the kids they tend the
gardens they do all the cooking
um it is a very demanding profession
and it's not something you can do in
your spare time and tribal
societies women tend to have very little
spare time compared to the men
it's obviously a sweeping generalization
but
sometimes a woman will feel a call to
heal and that is
what she'll do and she'll be the
equivalent of any
male shaman or sometimes even better but
they tend to be
outliers rather than oh yeah there's a
bunch of tribes that i know
where the primary shamans are women so i
would have to say in my experience
no but you know the amazon's a big place
and there's lots of tribes so
you may find different answers from
other ethnobotanists
within the tribes that you've spent time
this is going to sound like an odd
question but it's related to the
male female split among practitioners
and that is
what percentage this is i know it's a
lame question but
what percentage of the use of
hallucinogens specifically
is focused on hunting
aspects of hunting or warfare
maybe less so today but tribal warfare
you know
in my experience the tribes that i spend
considerable time with that are
very much into hallucinogens on a
regular basis
or in the northwest amazon and most of
the tribes i work with don't use
hallucinogens in the shingo in the
southeast
amazon in brazil the trios up on the
suriname
brazil border the guayanas on the
suriname french guiana border
the y wise on the surinam surinam guyana
border
so i i can't give you a straight answer
there tim i it doesn't break down very
easily
and uh most of the groups that i've
worked with warfare is definitely a
thing of the past
except for some of the anami when i
worked there 20 years ago spent time
there 20 years ago
there was still warfare amongst the
different villages but i think that's
gone by the wayside since then
and hunting and the reason i'm asking i
mean is i'm curious if
the disproportionate male representation
in working with some of these plants
is related to a disproportionate
traditional application to
hunting which i would assume in in many
of these cultures is predominantly male
but maybe that's an overreach i don't
know well i hadn't thought of that but i
think that makes very good sense
and the tribes that i've spent time with
that do a lot of ayahuasca
for example and yopl it's primarily for
hunting hunting visions hunting magic
good luck in the hunt seeing where the
animals are going to be
but as i said the anumami were still
doing some warfare very limited amount
and uh that was primarily the men and
the men were the ones doing
all the opal at least that i saw what do
you think
the and this is a heavy term so maybe
it's not the
right way to phrase it but the
responsibility if any
for people in the united states and
elsewhere who are
using these compounds from the amazon
to in some fashion support or protect
the communities
the people from which these medicines
came
and that's a loaded question so yeah you
can answer it however you want
i find it highly ironic that all these
people are talking about the vine of
life
don't look where the stuff's coming from
i've had humans complain to me they see
plane loads the stuff flying out of the
northwest amazon
they never got anything for it there was
no replanting they didn't know where it
went it was
it was a sacrilege to them so i would
like to think
that everybody should be thinking about
giving back whenever they benefit from
something and i'm not just talking about
hallucinogens
but there seems to be a lot or very
little interest
in in supporting these forests very
little interest in supporting the
shamans
other than okay this guy gave me the
brew to drink so
i got to slick him a few bucks it's just
kind of a disconnect
that it's all about healing but they're
not thinking about who they need to heal
as reciprocity for getting some of the
healing you know what i'm saying i do
is there anything they can do and this
could relate to
amazon conservation team or any number
of other things but i'm wondering
if people who are listening whether they
have benefited from
psychedelics whether derived from or
synthesized based on the molecular
structure of
natural compounds if they wanted to try
to support and certainly this is a great
time to support because not unlike the
native american communities in the
united states the indigenous tribes
certainly speaking with some of my
friends in south america are having just
an atrocious time
with covet 19 and having food supplies
cut off and
it being viewed in some ways as an
opportunity for governments to withhold
resources and it's
it's a very tragic situation so i think
that the timing
couldn't be better in a sense for
supporting
the communities from which a lot of
these medicines came
what can people do are there any any
steps you might recommend any things you
might
suggest they consider well what you're
saying i hear two questions tim
one is how should people give back that
are benefiting from this healing in
these plants in these fungi that's one
thing
and our organization is very active in
supporting the shamanic cultures the
northwest amazon which is where
ayahuasca
and the use of ayahuasca originated i'm
sorry to my brazilian friends who think
it all came from rio and sao paulo
no originally it came from the northwest
amazon in terms of helping indigenous
peoples
in the amazon they're getting hammered
by this virus
and it's particularly challenging in the
sense that
it's not like we've got the cure for
this and if we just had enough money
we'd give it to them
yeah i wish it was that simple it's not
we don't have the cure for it we know
the cure for them we don't have the cure
for it for us
but there are positive steps that can
and should be taken
and if you look at our website
amazonteam.org
you can see some of the things that
we've been doing which
is indigenous park rangers who control
the borders and keep the outsiders out
because that's how the disease gets in
number two educational materials in the
tribal language don't send in
a poster in in spanish or portuguese and
think okay they got it
also the educational material has to be
aimed
at a culturally appropriate way these
are tribal people they eat out of the
same pot
in the age of coronavirus you don't eat
out of the same pot
okay sometimes it's just sending in soap
they can make soap
from some local plants but not to the
degree that they need it now i mean i'm
washing my hands 20 times a day as we
all should be
so we not only recognize the problem
but we have programs in place to deal
with it
we have gotten over two tons of supplies
medical and sanitary supplies into the
hands of the indigenous peoples in the
northwest amazon
now on the one hand that's a pretty
impressive number on the other hand it's
pretty pathetic compared to the size and
scope of the of the problem in the
challenge
so we need more help we need more
support
to do more of this and partner with
other organizations
that can do more along the same lines so
we know there's a problem we know it's
getting worse i've lost two
we've lost two tribal leaders in the
amazon
in the last month who are spectacular
people
that you know there's no replacement for
and remember that the way that these
diseases strike
is they first and foremost hit the
elderly well the elderly are the
libraries the elderly are the ones that
have all the knowledge in their heads
and secondarily they hit the little ones
not necessarily coronavirus but some of
the other things that sweep through
so you're losing the elderly and using
the little ones which means you're
losing the library and you're losing
the next generation that's a lose-lose
proposition
and for those people interested they can
also follow
uh amazon conservation team on twitter
at amazonteam.org
and i'll link to that in the show notes
and you recently
just published a response dashboard
which is
quite impressive i'm impressed by it
which was built with something called
esri people can check out
at sri esri very very cool and
you can see visually how act
that is amazon conservation team a ct is
working to mitigate the threat posed by
kova 19
to the amazon rainforest most vulnerable
populations it's very cool it's very
well done
and it's a timely tool and it's a timely
problem if people have
had this in some fashion weighing on
their mind or if it just occurred to
them
that if they are a proponent of healing
modalities that include
plants or things derived from those
plants inspired by those plants
that this is a good time to sort of toss
your hat in the ring and
people can certainly find more about
what you do
at amazonteam.org well mark
we we could go in a million different
directions
is there anything else that you would
like to make sure we
mention or take some time to chat about
well i do have a story and i have a
concluding note which you can feel free
to edit in somewhere
i used to play a lot of racquetball and
i injured my arm
quite badly my forearm and for some
reason the muscles of your forearm don't
have a lot of venation they don't heal
well
on their own if you injure them a
certain way and i went to the doctor
i went to the masseuse same story as i
mentioned earlier with my foot it just
didn't get better
and i went to the shame and he looked at
it and he said um this is going to take
some time
so i spent a month there i mean i was
doing other things
but the first thing he did was give me
plants
as an a topical he rubbed them on a lot
of massage
gave me a drink so it was internal as
well
and then he said okay here's the problem
you have a bad relationship buried in
that muscle
that's why your doctors can't heal it
and i can
so i am going to chant and i'm going to
remove those bad emotions
because it'll just come back
so he did the chanting he did the
massage i drank the potion
and he said now here's the problem what
western medicine doesn't understand is
when you have a bad injury
things will come back and attack that
space so some people
you know when they're nervous they get
stomach aches or they get pimples or
they can't sleep
he says what i need to do is put a
shamanic patch
over where the wound was there's no more
wound i've healed it but i'm going to
put a patch
so it never comes back so when you have
stress or when you're injured it doesn't
start hurting again
that was about 13 years ago i'm still
fine
that's an explanation and approach to
healing which i've never heard from any
position and frankly i've never heard
from any other shaman but you know what
my arm doesn't hurt
so many interesting questions uh i love
interesting questions
you know i just want to make a quick
side note because i realized i didn't
answer it earlier i didn't explain it
you said lyanna earlier that is
a vine or a because a wooden
climbing plant that hangs from trees
is a woody vine that's what tarzan used
to swing on it's what ayahuasca is
yeah it's quite a cross section too
beautiful looking
beautiful looking vine not so delicious
looks better than it tastes
that's definitely true
and you said you had some closing
comments yeah
recently i was talking to a fellow
trying to
get some support for fighting covert 19
amongst the indigenous peoples of the
amazon and he said
act what does it stand for and i said
get [ __ ] done
he said well that doesn't match the
acronym i said is amazon conservation
team you want a mission statement i got
a mission statement
the point is we're about accomplishing
the goals
partnering with indigenous peoples to
protect their culture and their forest
and the challenge has never been greater
in the age of covid19
the point being that western medicine
doesn't have all the answers we don't
have a cure for covet-19 we don't have a
cure for coronavirus
neither do they but what we're able to
do is bring to bear western knowledge
and abilities and sanitation
and technology like to the new dashboard
to keep
track of this and try and devise the
means to keep it at bay as much as
possible
the future of conservation the future of
the rainforest the future of indigenous
peoples in my opinion
isn't about the microchip versus the
medicine man
it's both of them working together it's
about building bridges and building
alliances
and coming up with a new way of doing
things a new way of living our lives
a new way of stewarding nature and
it takes boundary walkers whether it's
the shamans who come out of the
rainforest
to enlighten us with their wisdom or
guys like you or me who've been down to
the rainforest to learn from them
or people that have feet in different
worlds or people that are just open to
hearing other
realities other modalities willing to
try
medicines or chanting or a frog slime
when western medicine wasn't able to do
the trick
so whether it is black lives matter
whether is it about saving the rain
forest all of these cries
should feed productively into a more
positive place
for all of us because conservation is
not just about saving the rainforest
conservation is not just about saving
the indians
conservation is about saving ourselves
as well
well mark we could talk for many many
more hours
and i hope to do that in person me too
and
this has been just a thoroughly
enjoyable conversation
and i really appreciate you taking the
time i think this gives people a lot to
chew on they can find
amazon conservation team at
amazonteam.org they can find your
personal website
at markplotkin.com i'll link to all of
those
in the show notes and people can find
those at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and just search
plotkin p-l-o-t-k-i-n
and it'll be it'll come right up or you
just search amazon and i'm sure it'll
also pop right up
this has been a blast i really
appreciate you taking the time i enjoyed
it at least as much as you did tim
well this will be this will be round one
and uh hopefully we'll get a round two
set up in person might be at a socially
appropriate distance
but tbd on that front and
so many more questions but i'll let
those sit for now
and thank you once again and to
everyone listening be safe keep your
mind
open and if you can support if you have
found benefit
from the plants the compounds that we're
describing
i feel like it is at least for me a
moral
imperative and quite frankly it's also
an existential imperative
if you are consuming these plants for
the compounds themselves
to support these geographies these
people
who have been the stewards of this
technology
these means of preparation and
administration for hundreds and
thousands
of years and an easy way to do that is
to go to amazonteam.org and see what
opportunities exist
doesn't need to be a lot of money i know
there are a lot of different causes
there are a lot of different
pains and a lot of uncertainty at the
moment but as you said
conservation is sort of the
fabric upon which many of these other
concerns
rest and it's all encompassing in some
respects
so i will say thank you uh mark dr mark
plotkin markplotkin.com
i definitely encourage people to take a
look at tales of a shaman's apprentice
as well as the amazon subtitle what
everyone needs to know
and until next time thanks for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by theragun
i have two theraguns and they're worth
their weight
in gold i've been using them every
single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my feet
it's helped with my plantar fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing and
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point
so i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's
thera t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n theragon risk-free
for
30 days there's no substitute for the
gen 4 theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragun app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragun.comtim
right now and get your gen4 theragun
today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine use them on their it
bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start
at just 199 i said i have two i have the
prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragon.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
pornhub
just kidding this episode is brought to
you by four sigmatic
which is part of my morning routine also
part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings
i regularly start with their mushroom
coffee instead of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60 percent of americans or
more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize chaga
it is nicknamed the king of the
mushrooms it is excellent for
immune system support so needless to say
i am focused on that right now myself
and so i will often have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out
every single batch is third party lab
tested for heavy metals allergens all
the bad stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer a 100
money back guarantee so you can try it
risk free why not
i've worked out an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic on their best-selling
lion's mane coffee i literally have a
mug
full of it in front of me right now and
this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39
off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39
off it's a lot their best selling lions
main coffee bundles to claim this deal
you must go to 4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on
their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t
dot com tim to get yourself some awesome
and delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
you